chapter 7 is specifically about the
[Music]
church yes chapter 7 is telling us a lot
about the history the historical
development of the Catholic Church and
we we already talked about a little bit
of this with you know where did the
different churches come from in the West
they spoke lacking in in the rest they
also underwent some some important
historical movements or events that took
a while one of which was the collapse of
Roman power the reason why the Catholic
Church and particularly the Roman
Catholic portion of the Catholic Church
became so influential in these area in
Western history is because there was a
power vacuum and when people live
together in some sort of you know
society there's a lot of things that
actually have to continue to happen you
know if the secular power disappears
there's a barbarian invasion economic
collapse in a lot of places you know a
lot of other issues coming up what are
the sort of things that have to happen
is that that only saying you know
somebody has to make sure that the
trains run on time obviously they don't
have trains but what are the really
basic elements of the social life they'd
have to continue let's say the time that
keeps you like disappeared as an entity
all the buildings are still there yeah
we turn on a TV or the radio our phones
we find out the federal government's
gone state of New York government is
also gone how many governments go what
the hell are we gonna do we start
looting everything you know it's gonna
be a holiday
forget class that might be funny for a
little bit it's happening you know
that's not really a great way to live is
it what do we need soon after that
yeah but just someone has to monopolize
the violence yeah and the church didn't
really do that have left it up though
you know local rulers who are supposed
to you know regulate things you know
oftentimes Kings and barons and nights
like that they've come down on a favor
doing the wrong stuff what you often
they work sometimes bishops actually
have enough holding secular power like
that it's all sorts of trials what else
but don't let anyone kill anybody
Rob anybody what are their functions the
society that has to have to continue if
you're going to have a society
yeah like some kind of structure to it
and they're like people follow a set of
rules yeah okay so you have to provide
something not just a bunch of laws but
actually some some sort of more ease
some sort of here's how we do things
here that people can count on the church
actually had its on the courts after a
while its mighty of courts to decide
issues between people right the church
in many places supplied education you
know you would send your kids to the
local monastery where they were educated
and they would it send your kids back
and they might actually be able to read
you know or do mathematics you know
those sorts of things that we take for
granted the church filled in many other
aspects of life and that's important to
keep in mind with respect to the
development of the Western Church he has
all the things came in as the state
became more powerful as the towns became
more powerful as economic changes
occurred there was a lot a lot of
struggle between these different these
different factors and there were always
some people saying thank God we don't
have to worry about that anymore in the
church and other people saying no it's
best if we hold on to that so there's
always this tension going on your book
also talks about something else that's
important with respect to the
Catholicism also with respect to to
orthodoxy where do you in fact get your
norms from for what it means to be a
Christian and how you know society ought
to be organized how to live
Christianity is what we call a revealed
religion meaning that like in many other
religions they believe that the divine
and somehow revealed a plan a norm the
way that human beings want to act think
behave and some of this for Catholics
is in terms of sacred documents the
Bible right scripture church remains
written that's all the other early
churches along with the Catholic Church
also accept it as equal to scripture
tradition and you can say position with
a capital T yeah
this means this sort of ongoing process
by which the church as a body figures
out of the things that it needs to
figure out not everything is going to be
found in the Bible you know so think
about those church councils for example
that would be part of tradition some
people would put the writings of the
church fathers in there as normative and
then for the Roman Catholic Church and
all the other Eastern Churches are there
you know these other rights within it
you have something that's a bit
different
it's called Magisterium magisteria means
teaching authority the Magisterium would
be the Pope the bishops the bishops all
together and as a council definitively
deciding things and you know so when
when for examples Pope Francis comes in
why why is that important just nice guy
and he'll say Mass nicely he's actually
supposed to be a decider he's supposed
to set the agenda so what he writes
things like these papal encyclicals
they're supposed to actually you know
set the tone they're supposed to be in
some respects equal in dignity and in
showing what what God wants to these
other things yeah if it's it's a
distinctively Catholic thing to see this
as equal to the content or that that's
kind of old
Magisterium into tradition for process
for the most part there will be a few
exceptions it's just that's just
scripture Sola scriptura scripture alone
this is one of the hallmarks of the
possible information so this is
something very important to know about
the structure of these these older
churches in about the Catholic Church
your book talks about you know if you
want to look at Roman Catholic Church
each of those words has a important
meaning you know Rome the Bishop of Rome
Catholic meaning universal it really is
understood as a church that's supposed
to be like going to the ends of the
world and then you know church the
ecclesial community the bringing
everything together having a sort of you
know vision of life as a totality so you
know just to use an example
Pope Francis do you guys been following
the news he ticked off if you're poking
I was gonna take off somebody if you're
holding any bit of authority and it
really just you'll take off somebody
Pope Francis ticked off a lot of
conservative Catholics recently what do
you do what do what are you saying what
kinds of things
yeah and he said you know being Catholic
is not about being anti-gay I don't I
don't have that in mind although that
wouldn't that was something that you
know people like you said that about gay
rights who said that about worship these
are not one single deciding factors
something more economic terms the
Socialist Pope a lot of very
conservative Catholic friends because I
face book and I went to Catholic High
School and a lot of my friends you know
you get into your 30s 40s a lot of them
kind of get kinda conservative yeah and
when he came out and said you know
capitalism really needs have some limits
on it what you did and some people
addresses like I can't believe it
he's a communist he's a socialist
actually you know what he was saying is
the same thing that other folks before
he mo said including John Paul and lead
over thirteen you know there's been
longtime part of tradition and a guru on
Scripture to do that these are all sort
of good examples why does the Pope
saying anything about economics should
he just like stick to religious stuff
and mind his own business when it comes
to the marketplace well this goes to
what your book is talking about as
Church as opposed to sort of set narrow
it's us over here and the rest of you
stay away we can separate ourselves off
from the world churches in this classic
sense or understood as being tied in
with all the other aspects of life so
that's going to bring about certain
certain tensions you have some
discussions here about the different
sacraments but we've already talked
about those a bit so I you know the book
has a good
none of that and how they fit in with
the sort of cycle of you know going from
birth all the way to death but I'm going
to skip over that to talk about a few of
other things
another thing that's considered to be
distinctively Catholic really is really
all pre-reformation churches is the
veneration mary and the saints and you
might say why this wife set Mary aside
isn't she was one of the saints well
she's understood as being a mother of
God they don't OCO since we talked about
remember the Council of Nicaea
it concerns that a bit right there no
I'm sorry defeatist sort of that so
veneration of Mary and the Saints you
know this notion of praying to Saints as
intercessors to get them to help out
with certain things
those are you to come from a Catholic
background if I were to say the saint of
hopeless causes would that be is that
still a thing these days was for my
generation no st. Jude you know
something like well I don't it's
hopeless pray to this thing and there
tends to be always sort of a thin line
between like a superstitious attitude
towards this and an understanding of
what these things are about how do
people get to be Saints just by the
answering prayers and having tons of
power in theory you know that there are
some saints who like had to be
people corresponding to them really made
a lot of people man
but in Gemini how does it work those are
the exceptions
what are Saints there hold right make
some hole yeah exactly cameras like
saying hey yeah I'm holy everyone says
oh we'll take you to see someone that
you actually have you know what they did
yeah you know very often these are very
tough things to do you know think about
martyrs for example one is some category
of saints martyrs generally got you know
really beat up badly or killed for
saying I I believe usually by people who
said if you don't stop saying that stuff
we're going to kill you
well I gotta say in any way that takes a
lot of guts other Saints character for
people demonstrated there are actually
models to certify for example up or
faith devotion caring for other human
beings even if there's people you don't
like you know now why why did the Saints
become very important in in all the
early churches there's a lot of theories
of Memphis one is that it allowed you
know if God is this kind of shadowy
distant figure it's easier to to see a
connection to somebody who's a little
bit more like you because every sink
started out as some some schmuck
generally who wasn't a saint and then
there was some sort of process of
becoming better
it's easier to relate to than somebody
who's like good right off the bat is
enough that would be for me and that's
one theory there's a lot of other
different theories out there about that
but we're gonna we're gonna skip over
that a bit your book also talks about
monasticism again which we're going to
skip over it talks about purgatory
purgatory is something that again is
also distinctive to Catholic theology
what is exposition spend a few few brief
moments on this and again they're gonna
oversimplify here how does the notion of
purgatory is it like this so if you're
if you're good where do you go if you're
beyond you go to the terrible place and
if you're totally good and kind of bad
but didn't really have your act together
then you go to purgatory is that the way
the idea works basically or is your part
of the story than that
[Applause]
well you're right
these are like three cat holding places
the early Christians you know just
heaven in hell and you know Catholics
realized that a lot of people are kind
of in-between so you know a new layer
Steve a purgatory
leaning makes ready wait wait you're
gonna go oh so to be like it'd be like
this maybe you go from purgatory to hell
if you go to heaven usually a happy
event
but maybe you could really screw up in
purgatory you know they'd let you in on
the they're gonna let you in
provisionally Friday don't screw it up
and and you actually do screw it up so
they say well I guess tells the place
where it doesn't work like that
then we make a great thing people don't
make a great play the idea is that
purgatory means a place of purification
yeah and there's various theologies
about this one of them being that you
say that something for example but that
you wouldn't want to actually be in the
presence of God in heaven without being
purified of everything that's you know
screwed-up about you and that you know
explained to you that way purgatory
would actually be kind of a good place
to be because it's first off it's not
help right is this something that's
completely or distinctively Catholic
some of the early churches actually
thought that we should pray for those in
hell because we made thereby save them
there's always a controversial belief
that something awful lot like this this
doctrine but I really point this out to
you sort of account the distinctive
something else that your book talks
about now when you talk about these
Catholic distinctives somebody also your
book talks about is what we might call
process of hardening and relaxing in
history the Protestant Reformation takes
place as a reformation of the Catholic
Church origin the Martin Luther we're
going to talk about this next class
period started out as a Catholic didn't
mean to quit being a Catholic the church
had gone through a number of reforms at
different points Luther was calling some
progressively more and more radical
things at the time that he actually
nailed up to 96 theses 95 I mean says he
actually said I don't have a problem
with doctrine of purgatory later on II
sort of you know hardens disposition
about as the Reformation takes place and
we're going to see this next class
period all sorts of you know once you
open the doors all sorts of new ideas
and doctrines many of them sort of
trying to trace themselves back to early
Christianity come onto the scene and
they have a lot of energy a lot of force
behind them and the Reformation is
Protestant what happens to the Catholics
at that time do they say well hang out
over here with us there's actually can
coordinate of Catholic doctrine that
takes place something that we call a
Counter Reformation nowadays it's more
fashionable to call it the Catholic
Reformation because the large party did
consistent trying to strip away things
that were seen as mistakes and one of
the key events to associate with this is
what they call the Council of Trent call
this Catholicism Trat Trat becomes true
then you know the Tridentine yeah so you
know from the buffest
the you know the beginning well the
middle of the Reformation all the way to
the 20th century you have this this kind
of consolidation of Catholic doctrine of
ways of doing things things got kind of
fixed in place what changed
a lot of social forces that change that
we're not gonna have time to go into all
the ins and outs of this but if the role
of what we call the Vatican to the
Second Vatican Council and one is that
happening in the 1960s so actually from
62 to 64 I remember right dirty'
recently I had to do with you know
here's one example of it the mobile and
turning the the priest from facing away
from the congregation to facing towards
the congregation no longer doing the
mass of Latin which very few people
could understand is actually doing it in
the vernacular of the country in this
case usually English so we're going to
touch on this in later chapters but this
gives you kind of a thumbnail sketch of
where we're going and hopefully now if
you didn't know some things about
Orthodox and Catholics you actually have
some idea who these people are